[Music]  [Music]  what are you doing  oh i was just playing with this lamp oh  i'm star short for star break assume  yours is barbara  nope just barb plain old barb  i want to thank barbara stark we're  hosting tonight's talking club  and we're making their hot dog soup i  like the salt i like the hat dad  it's not as runny as it usually is  she gives me bigger teeth love big teeth  she loves big teeth even if it's just  two eyes on a  bunch of teeth look my new phone case  i love it it's like i'm listening to the  ocean wait we don't have cell phones  i know i'm gonna take it home and glue  it to our landline  i'm barb and this is star roll number  again please sir six  eleven six eleven oh my barb  oh my god she's six eleven six eleven  we're in 124  [Music]  holidays  you